adapt disperse recovery we're the
limited adaptive meaning then you have
just a few rounds about activity also
same problem as doing multi pass heavy
hitters in a turn of South Stream so so
for the talk
I think first going to just describe the
problem then the K equals one case is
what we already know we've known for
years and I'll just explain how the
algorithm and the lower bounds work for
that and then the goal of this talk is
to extend this to learning multiple
coordinates hired of a higher K and will
give both a lower and new upper bound
for that so again we're talking about
sparsity so a vector the same problem
that Peter was talking about if you have
if the most frequent frequent
coordinates appear much more often than
the less frequent ones then then in
order to estimate the vector you only
really need to find those large
coordinates and so we're going where our
hope is to find a vector that is close
to this approximately sparse vector it's
projects first because it has maybe a
power-law zipfian distribution and so
for instance if i want to estimate an
image this image is not very sparse but
if you take it into a different basis
like the wavelet basis then this is some
recursive thing where where large
corners correspond to edges and so in
this other basis images do tend to be
fairly sparse and so lots of data has
sparsity in some basis and the goal is
to use that use that structure of your
data to estimate it well so the first
recovery or compressed sensing problem
which for turnstile streams is almost to
equivalent to the heavy hitters or the
frequency estimation problem is that you
have some vector X and you know what
basis it's sparse in but you don't know
what the vector X is and instead you can
learn you can see linear measurements of
it
so why are linear measurements
interesting it's because in lots of
different modalities of access to your
data it's sort of easy and hardware to
get these linear measurements so one
example is in genetic testing you can
you can like this simple genetic test
you like take a drop of somebody's blood
and you measure do they have this
disease but you can also mix together
different people's blood and then then
you've got a linear combination if you
measure how much of the mutation is in
this blood and so you can get and so
indirect testing you can get a linear
combination in routers you can observe
you can store a X and then when a new
input comes like a new IP address that
just affects one coordinate of X and so
you add the corresponding column of a so
you can store a times X plus Delta just
your previously stored value plus a
times Delta until you're storing this
lower dimensional thing and in some
single pixel camera you put a filter for
the lens and so so there's lots of
different places where you can do linear
measurements and the question is how how
useful is this and so the goal here is
to get close to to find X there's lots
and lots of papers on this and one
formalization of this problem is that
we're going to choose some distribution
matrices on your linear sketch matrices
and then you give it a X you want to
estimate X and we'll say that the error
in your estimate is proportional to the
distance from X to its nearest caseware
approximation and so if you have a
zipfian distribution then the largest
coordinates are large and after you drop
the top K they're very small so if it's
1 over I power law then that's l2 norm
converges and you get very good error in
estimating concordance
and this is standard non-adaptive sparse
recovery we're talking this talk is
adaptive machines multipath so instead
of choosing so instead of Serapis
recovery we can do it in K log and
measurements we're going to choose a
first matrix a 1 C a1 X and now we're
going to choose a 2 X
choose a 2 and C a 2 X choose a 3 and
say C a 3 X and so in all of these in
many modalities it makes sense that you
can do this but often it's costly and so
you want to minimize the number of times
need to go back to your input and
measure it again and yes if your C is
enough the constant factor it doesn't
matter because you can take whatever
your output is and take the top K and
then I'll just lose a factor of 2 if you
want 1 plus Epsilon
then you get different answers depending
if it's proper or not and the dependence
of Epsilon but for this talk we're not
going to care about the Apple
independence right so you can't do that
if it's if it's truly streaming but if
you have say you're like often you use
streaming algorithms because you're
streaming it from where it's stored on
some data center like you're doing if
you're using it for a MapReduce so do it
using right so for the router you can't
do multi pass but for other applications
of streaming algorithms you can do multi
pass but it's expensive you don't want
to do 100 passes you'd like to do maybe
two passes three passes
not just confused because I feel
processing the data new item comes but
what happens toward previous leaving
this in this way right so you saw in one
pass you can this is not for one passer
oh this is for multi pass assets and so
the question is if I can do a two pass
algorithm does it take K log n linear
measurements right we know that it that
a one pass out of the requires K log n
measurements so what happened with the
two pass and so what some work I did in
grad school with Peter and David is is
we showed that if you can do many passes
so if I don't care how many passes I do
I do some order a log log an x log star
n passes then you can decrease this from
K log n linear measurements down to K
log log n and but this wasn't for
limited activity so this is one result
as many other results in in adaptive
recovery so if you care about the
dependence on epsilon then the first
works said okay
we'll take the same number of
measurements as you require non
adaptively
and we'll show that you can get a better
dependence on epsilon so first couple
works looked at K equals one and then
they were able to generalize it to
general K and then we looked at it and
said actually you can get you could
decrease the number of measurements and
a recent result by David and his
co-authors shows in fact you can
separate it separate the epsilon and the
N dependence so that you can do it in
basically K over epsilon plus K log
the upper bound is with many dogs this
is with many rats that's right so this
is again with like log log n time locks
are ok and then the lower bounds so airy
and Candice and devil are no fairies
here so that you can't improve the
epsilon dependence that you need k over
epsilon you know maybe you can remove
this log log water epsilon and then we
showed for K equals one that you need
log log n well this leaves the question
can you separate the K and the end just
as you can separate the epsilon in the
end this is where we were stuck for a
while and so so just to review we knew
that the optimum for constant epsilon
was between k plus log log n and k times
log log n and the question is which and
so what we were able to show here s for
constant r then you can do the k equals
1 version in log to the 1 over R and so
you can get the lower bound is k plus
log of 1 over R the upper bound is K
times log to the well 1 over R minus 3
so this is another another recent result
by David and it's the same one that got
the separate that plugin you can also
you could instead instead of separating
epsilon and you could decrease the
number of rounds to only have three
extra rounds and so what we show is for
the cost of our the lower bound is K
times log to the 1 over R n so you do
need to have this relationship and the
upper bound you don't need the extra
rounds with some log start ok excess
number of atoms and this comes from what
we know how to do for non adaptive high
SNR recovery and if we could remove that
then you could remove the lock star K
here is the log star K inside the log
it's not inside but log log star versus
[Laughter]
right so but there is a caveat here
which is the lower bound only applies if
K is relatively small so rather than K
equals 1 we can do it up to 2 to the log
of the 1 over R which if you think about
it that means you can get this bound if
the bound you get is bigger than K log K
so it's if so if R equals 2 this is
saying if K log K is less than K rool
again then it requires K root log and
measurements even in to round multipaths
screaming to do matters these are our
row complexity we're just carrying their
linear measurements so they don't give
you assuming lower ones
so I haven't thought about getting them
so yeah I would not yeah I haven't
thought of it
yeah drink to compare the two what is
like he seems to break down when you go
above system so I mean our algorithms so
the lower bound it works largely for
super cousin it's just that the bound
you get this log of the one over R is
going to become very small and there's
some polynomial in R dependence so you
can get something but it's a little bit
harder to describe what you get for the
upper bound there like the way we do it
has I think an exponential in R
dependence and so yes you can get
something we're super concentrate but
again it's not very good yeah and then
if and then above this caveat this
threshold of K log K or two to the loop
log with 1 over R n as long as you're
less than and a little over 1 you still
get something that's bigger than K so
you say you can't suddenly separate K
and then when you go to high K what we
don't have the time
okay so we didn't understand how this
works let's first think about K equals
one case because that's the way we
actually know how to do so when K equals
one the the theorems that we had like
six years ago showed that it requires r
times log of the 1 over RN measurements
in arms and so first we'll see when our
it goes 1 why it requires log n
measurements and then we'll see how you
can break this if you can do an addict
if ax t and then we'll see how to extend
the lower bound to get the log log so
the hard case in general the hard case
for all this talk will be that you have
a single coordinate that's 1 and every
other coordinates gonna be Gaussian and
the gaussians are going to be fairly
small and so the LTL to guarantee
requires you to be able to find this
chord okay I've seen the less than 1/10
and a 3 approximation you still need to
find that court because it's really
really important and so this coordinate
is at some position Z there's n possible
positions so you need to learn log n
bits to describe Z and yet the
observation right V dot X I could I can
choose any vector V I get V dot X which
is V sub Z plus V dot this Gaussian
noise which is itself just a Gaussian
right so you're gonna see V sub Z plus
some scale Gaussian where this scaling
is also dependent on the normal V and so
what does that mean that means for some
Z as a function of Gaussian noise I'll
get some Gaussian for a different Z I
would get a Gaussian centered at a
different value the other VC a
difference you'll get a different value
and so the situation you be in is well I
get one of sample from one of these I
need to figure out which one of that one
they are and so you can distinguish a
few of these but if there's too many of
them then you're not going to really be
able to learn that much information and
so if you think about that this is the
additive white Gaussian noise channel
its classic this is what Shannon
analyzed in 1948 when he invented
information theory and he showed that
the
the information capacity of this channel
is bounded by the log of the
signal-to-noise ratio where the signal
knowledge ratio is the ratio of the
variance of the signal to the variance
of the noise what is that that is the
expectation of these sub Z squared
divided by the 2 squared over n because
of the scaling it and that well Z is
random so that's just 1 as I said that
you're seeing a noise ratio is constant
and so the amount of information you get
in any single measurement is constant
but you need to learn log n bits to find
Z so it takes log n measurements if
you're doing it on a topic so person is
how does this change if I can do say 2
passes or he knew many passes and the
first round is still true then you only
get one bit for measurement but in the
later rounds you have some information
and what is your information say it
means that in the later rounds
conditioned on what you know you could
you v and z are not independent there's
gonna be some dependence because I know
something about Z and when I choose me
and so it's still true that I can get
only log of the SNR and my SNR is the
ratio between the expected value of V
sub Z squared to the norm over N but now
that expectation is not 1 and as we
learn about where Z is we can focus our
met our measurements on that those
positions we can learn more information
per measurement so to see how this could
work we start out we don't have any idea
where it is and so we get set V say to
be negative one first half and one on
the second half of the input and then we
would get a sample from you like one
Gaussian or the other and so we get
maybe one bit of information if we get
from the other left we figure out on the
left if we get something on the right if
we're on the road but now we can
restrict we know that our it measurement
is on in some subset so we can set V to
be zero everywhere else so get the same
amount of signal but we get zero noise
we'll get much less noise because we're
gonna move this half if you can learn
more bits and so then as we
do this once we've learned B bits of
information we're going to read
restricting the signal to a 1 and n over
B sized region which means we're going
to get rid of our n over 2 and over 2 to
the B size region we're going to get rid
of most of the noise our noise got to go
down by a factor 2 to the B and so we
can fit in about 2 to the B gaussians
and still identify them and so if we've
learned B bits of information so far we
can get another B bits of information in
a single measurement so information is
growing exponentially in log log n
bounds we're going to be able to get log
n bits and in one if I just have two
rounds then I learned one bit per round
the first and the per measurement of the
first first round so I do route log n
measurements in the first round and
learn route log and X and now we can
learn route log n bits per measurement I
do route log n measurements I get R log
n bits if that's how you get the roulade
so this is
the other round now how do we get a
lower bound so we'd like to say is at
every stage we have some posterior Pete
on where Z is and this reflects will
having learned B bits of information
which is how much the entropy of P is
less than logging and the lemma that one
can show is that the that now whatever V
you choose the mutual information
between the measurement you get VX and
where Z is is bounded by B plus one and
so how do we do this well again our mix
information is bounded by look that
Shannon Hartley but now because that we
can choose V and P is not uniform this
would be about 1 plus n times the
maximum value of P because you could
choose V to be all entirely on the
largest value of P and so if P were
roughly uniform then this would be about
n over 2 to the B this would give you
the right bound of B the problem is it
is much too weak when P when your
distribution is non-uniform that's lazy
this Shannon Hartley theorem on capacity
is only accurate like it's tight if
their posterior if the signal you send
is a Gaussian and if it's very much non
Gaussian that it can be very inaccurate
and so what we need to say we need to
get something better if we have very
skewed distribution for P and
particularly way we're going to do this
is we the way we do this is we partition
P by the level sets so the set the level
you're in says that you're about to the
J factor larger than knowing nothing and
you can show that the expected level
that you lie in this big right so you
can always be in a sock in coordinates
of value 2 to the B over N that would be
just a uniform distribution on n over 2
to the B things or you can have a much
smaller chance of being much larger
and then we can bound the mutual
information by the mutual information
conditioned on what level you're in plus
the entropy of finding the level year
and then shed hardly can show that in
any given level your mutual information
is bounded by than the L infinity norm
of P in that level which was to the J
and log of that so you get J for any
given level J because the expected level
is B this would give you order B as the
mutual information and you can also show
that the entropy of the level is B and
so overall you get a mutual information
per measurement to is B so this is a key
level lets you solve it for k equals 1
the question is how do we extend this to
general so this says that suppose they
have two rounds in order n bits in the
first round where I'm squirting the bits
in the second round therefore M need to
be at least root log in general you get
the banners that we
so what happens for general K so let's
let's take the proof out lie and see how
can we extend this to general K so we
had Co coordinate plus noise we take our
posterior that has B bits of information
and we showed this key lemma that the
mutual information in any new measure
the amount of information get from any
new measurement is order B what happens
we're done okay well the natural thing
is just take K independent copies right
we want to say that to ink a it takes K
times more information so we'll just
take K gaussians or k coordinates within
gaussians extender domain by a factor of
Kappa formalize this so now that now
instead of having a single Z we're gonna
have a k2 pool of Z's
we have some posterior for the previous
measurements which have some information
content which is now not log n minus a
to P but K log n nice HIV because that's
the posterior is over k tuples and the
question is now what lemma do we want to
show previously we showed that the
information was B plus 1 given B bits
you can learn B then well what do we
want now
so that's the thing would be to try just
the same bound that information is still
doesn't be and this is true you can show
it but it's not good enough at all
because then we get K log n to the 1
over R instead of K times log to the 1
over R 10 I get log of K log n instead
of K log log so what we want to say is
something like given K be bits of
information I can only get about B over
K bits about each one because each
coordinate the average quarter not only
have the over K bits of information
about it and back and um probably that
this bound isn't true it's false because
I could just I could start out only
learning the first coordinate I know I
can learn if I learn log n over 2 bits
in the first coordinate then the next
round I can still learn log n bits and
so it's not it's just not true that the
amount of information that I learned a
single measurement can be B over K let
me think about it that examples is
saying that there can be some
coordinates that's so far you've learned
much more than average and there and
then in the next time you're going to
learn even more more than average so
maybe you can throw out to the
coordinates that are too long and so if
I opposed to apply Markov inequality I
could hope to say maybe most of the
coordinates 99% of the coordinates only
have order B over K bits of information
about them and therefore on those
coordinates I'm only going to get order
B over K bits of information and this is
one one reason you would require are to
be constant because I throw it a
constant fraction at each stage I can
only set R to be constant and so this
would be the goal maybe we'll find some
subset of coordinates and see the
information about them is only order B
ever K
this would be strong enough for Carson
our and it's true if your distribution
is a product distribution that is if
your information is independent about
each of the coordinates there's no
reason that needs to be true and in
general this is false so if if I knew
something correlated about my different
coordinates say I knew that the parodies
of the indices were all the same then
they can make a measurement that gets a
lot more information about everybody I
don't I don't know how to but maybe you
could show something based cuz you've
got a linear measurements but I don't
but they can be correlated information
if I give some linear measurements I'll
learn something about what's happened
but it can be correlated information and
so I can have some correlation structure
on my posterior distribution on the
coordinates and I don't know how to
describe it other than you only have B
base overall
and so what we're gonna get instead is B
over K plus log K bits so this
correlation structure can give you more
information but only up to a log care
okay them goodbye Kochi shortened lose a
factor of K so this will be true and
it's strong enough if the log K doesn't
matter and why wouldn't the log K matter
it wouldn't matter to be or K is bigger
than log K and so in the first round you
don't need this because it's not
adaptive you know it's uniform you only
get constant and so as long as by the
second round you've already gotten K log
K bits in the log K don't matter and
this is what you need to get learn and
so that's why we're gonna have that
restriction that K log K is less than
how did you prove this well again fly
data processing a chat heartily you get
some longer the signal noise ratio but
the signal noise ratio is now the
expectation of the sum over my K
coordinates squared of their value
squared that's a little annoying so we
apply Kochi shorts and change the sum
squared to the square to the sum of the
squares routines large factor of K and
now this is really an average over the
different chunks
oh how what their sigmoids ratio is
within that shock you have your
measurement that I saw min chunk once
some one chunk to this is the average of
the signal noise ratios and so as long
as no chunk has two highest signal noise
ratio this will be done so you want to
say that we can find as large subset of
coordinates so it's that note so that
they all have bounded signal noise ratio
and as we saw in the cave goes one
there's this other issue of the level
sense and so instead what we have is
that on average over all coordinates and
overall the over the level set that you
happen to lie in this log is got to be
bounded and so we have some situation
where there's many coordinates and
you're going the X will happen to lie in
some level set here and most of them are
going to be good you mean the
information about that corn in that
level set is order B over K but some of
them they're gonna be bad but usually
you're gonna be able to find some large
set of coordinates that are good and so
99% of the time you're gonna find that
point 99 K such that the maximum missin
R is bounded by B over K
as that gives us the key level that we
need which is now a little bit
we're awkward because we're gonna saving
yet be over cables la caper measurement
plus an additional B plus K factor which
comes from this H of J term if you're a
call from the K equals one the entropy
of your partition is now B buscan phew
so if you look at how do is it's done in
K equals one you said that the
information was bounded by the
information conditioned on J plus h MJ
then racing conditional on J was order B
plus one the entropy of J would be plus
one and now you do the same thing except
this is now SNR log of the SNR in the
Union which is bounded by K times the
maximum which is bounded by your k+
blockade
into the movie say is the first found is
that on doctor we only learned order
round bits in the second round we can
learn em times Buick a plus log gang
those people okay and so if your number
of measurements is larger than lot then
K log K the dominant term is MB over K
giving you m squared over K yes so you
need since you need to learn K log n
bits
this means K M needs jelly's K root log
n so the big questions here are first
can we avoid the restriction on cat and
so as that you know when he wrote this
paper we didn't belissa how to do it i
when i was made preparing this talk I
realized another option for that key
lemma that I think might make this work
which is to condition look at about Dean
for mutual inflation conditioned on the
coordinates that you throw out and I
don't have a counter example to this
being B over k plus 1 and this would
supposed and then a separate question is
get a better dependence on R so as R
goes to infinity then we don't know how
to say anything because of this entropy
of the partition meaning that we that
every round we could get a lot more
information so the lower back
go briefly over the Oh okay you can get
something for very slightly superclass
on our right you can look at the paper
to see what the dependence is not for
larger
so for the other bound again we have the
optimal one sparse recovery act and we
want to turn this into a case partial
coming up and there's a standard way
that it happens in a lot of papers for
doing that and has three steps first you
throw your coordinates into buckets then
in each bucket you try one sparse
recovery if there is exactly one heavy
hitter and not too much noise you'll
find it and then that'll get you 90% of
the heavy hitters and you clean up the
mistakes either by recursion or some
other technique and the problem is these
extra steps they add rounds they require
doing something new with new rounds and
so in a Knick place Woodruff we studied
step three recursively it's that meant
that we took log stark a recursive round
to say the number of rounds blowed up by
a factor of order log star okay
backer she and moonroof improve this to
being only one run in the beginning to
round at the end but it still means you
have three extra rounds and so if you I
want a two pass algorithm you can't get
anything so question is how can we avoid
these extra rounds and we're going to do
a different approach which doesn't look
at the K equals one case instead it's
going to reduce to higher signal noise
ratio sparse case parse recover which we
know how to solve and nearly optimal K
log base C of
so the basic approach would be we throw
into K times 2 to the root log n buckets
and now we do case press recovery this
is takes K log n over K is K log to the
rule again is K root log n measurements
and then now that I've restricted to
this much smaller subset right so now
I've thrown out most of the coordinates
because it'll land in a different bucket
and so the coordinates that are remained
will have will be enriched
they'll have much higher signal noise
ratio and so I apply high signal noise
ratio C equals 2 to the root log in
sparse recurrent approximate recovery at
K log base C of n which is again kaeru
log N and so the overall number of
measurements is KT log n the problem is
that I can't miss anything
because my goal is to avoid having to do
this cleanups round and so I need to
ensure that this case press recovery in
this projected domain doesn't lose
anything important and there will be
collisions so even if things come on I
need to find that bucket just to know
that it's preimage is important so we
have this eye this technique of [ __ ]
Gaussian hashing that does it so for
intuition suppose my vector looks like
this this case Bart's binary plus a
little bit of Gaussian noise it's very
small so that you need to find almost
every quarter so given some partition
throwing it into buckets the question is
how so within a bucket there's many
coordinates that are supposed to go
there how should I combine them to get
this lower dimensional vector so the
most common technique that you see is
they do it with random socks so I said
why in a given bucket to be the sum over
everything that passes to this bucket of
the value times the random sign so just
as a picture if I take this and I do
this and I do this sign projection I get
this value and if you notice there's
three coordinates here there were five
coordinates here what happened is two of
them land in the same bucket and they
happen to have canceling signs and so
you got zero
and so you're not gonna find them and so
this means you're not even without noise
the sign projection doesn't work another
he had even with noise it doesn't do
much worse because if you hash if you're
not if you don't collide you've got to
be pretty big and so the noise doesn't
mess you up very much an alternative
solution would be to use gaussians
instead of random signs I do it with
gaussians then when I do it without
noise I'm in good shape
they'll see this coordinate didn't
appear here it appears here all the the
entire image of the heavy hitters will
appear just because a real number isn't
gotten easier problem is now bard values
can become small and so with noise
they're not gonna be able to find this
coordinate these small coordinates you
can lose something with noise and so the
approach we take have is just choose
three different captions and turns out
three is the right number if I do three
of them then sure you can miss a
coordinate a bucket in one of the hashes
but the chance that you missed it in
three Hatter's is pretty small and it
gets smaller the bigger the more the
more important it is to find a
coordinate because the bigger it is the
less likely you're gonna miss it all
three times and so overall the expected
mass of the false negatives is order the
noise metal and so it's fine to miss and
so you don't need to do any cleanup
round and since you don't need to do any
cleanup round you get K log to the one
over R and yeah yeah so if you think
about this this example where you just
have binary so we don't know what this
press recovery algorithm will do it
could say drop anything drop the
smallest have you hit our images and so
it can
okay so the image of a coordinate has a
1 in K to the one-third chance of being
less than K the 2/3 and then you can
miss all of them and so you can have a 1
in K to the 1/3 chance of missing a one
of these binary times so if three that
becomes one over K and so you miss on
average one which is what this noise
level tolerance
this is the key idea that lets us get
the nearly optimal for until we get K
root log n times a log star K alright
good okay so so with signs it's not
gonna work because you without noise
you're not a lot you can't miss anything
and right so this coordinate has two
heavy hitters in it if I find it three
times there'd still be a 1/8 chance that
I miss it entirely and so you need to be
that you miss nothing if there's no
noise and if gaussians you miss nothing
if there's no noise for the doses but
the same hash in the same age that's
right this image yeah you could try
different ages but even so you don't
want your buckets to be much bigger than
order K and so you still would have a
constant factor of missing things with
signs
yeah
okay so to summarize previously it was K
plus root log n at lower bound now is K
times root log n has a lower bound and
they said K is not too big and the upper
bound avoids the extra passes at this
cost of a log star K which will be
removed if we can improve see
approximate recovery for hi-c and
there's lots of open questions as you
can see I achieved I think the biggest
one that had a conceptual I just I don't
know how to approach is to say as if R
is really unlimited like bigger than K
and you can't do any better and I could
imagine that these techniques might
improve to our being like log log n but
about above that I don't know how to
have it get it at all thank you
[Applause]
automatic question so your paper was
Bora the monkeys like you studied what
happens if you do random measurements or
what would the price rented by a bygones
right yeah do you have a sense you find
that physical activity
yeah so this question is if you don't
have sparsity but you have some other
structural assumption then can you
benefit from an activity and my guess
would be that it depends a lot on the
structural assumption that you have that
in the generality we had in that so it
was referencing a paper if your know
your distribution comes from the output
of some generative model like again then
you can get something very generally and
I doubt you get something
so I have a question here but the
captions just mentioned like three
options he's really polar icecaps in so
it reduces videos like properties of
those uniform would be good it's just
what they got so we use the property
value so we want it to be the case that
when you have collisions that only helps
so if i have collisions that is just
gonna be more likely that I find that
coordinate now by the central limit
theorem needing to converge to a
Gaussian so yes probably if you did
random uniform between negative 1 1
negative 1 and 1 it would work like
really we do use that but but what we
really need is anti concentration of
some of this stuff
so because it's stable the sum is a
Gaussian source and it concentrated but
you could have other other distributions
and they would still aunty
thank you very much wake up